[Music]
so Oh see where my hand is to the elbow
it's not over here it's definitely not
here and then this hand's gonna go
underneath and then I have the truck so
here near near that over here near the
elbow hit in the face that would be the
line then boom
you know she should get rid right again
that's cute kid hey wait every rift now
its own fit not tough like a comment
okay let it take this has been said many
times here so you older people should
already have this right now okay
go okay so see how she's leaning that
way go ahead and do it go ahead right
see I am too strong for that go ahead
and try it it's not gonna happen okay
then go ahead and get it go ahead and
get it all kids I'll let you get Kate
wait there hang out there okay now
here's where you wouldn't you'd normally
tap out but this arm is free to move do
you understand so once I have this arm
free to move I can use it to change the
location ever so slightly of the
relationships between my arm your levers
and fulcrum so you got it okay
watch now it's off you see you could be
a matter of just pushing into you and
it's off and I'm out
it could be a matter of pushing up
because it was weakness there it's off
again right in other words if you're
trying to rest me here's where you're
gonna start bricks you got it
so
this cannot be a pinch and you should
not think of it as a pin because of the
other arm allows the person to change
the geometry of my pinning technique got
it do you understand so what is keyhole
was up right okay be more specific
beginner training no no don't don't
advance people do it what is it okay
architectural trained someone give me
better than that but no drills for what
body conditioning body conditioning body
organization you got it okay so that's
all I'm gonna do here so I missed in
this position you see unwind your
I'm not gonna go live this CICU can
unwind
you can't go so what I have to do
instead is learn how to have it already
be done you see it's already done so I'm
doing coke you whole settling not
torquing her arm
I'm just here do you see spine straight
right there's a lot of downward pressure
right if you want go ahead and wiggle
either you can't it's gonna hurt but you
can do it you see that wipe it down
harder maybe you can't go that way so go
the other way push your arm push this
towards me push it this way really hard
don't worry there you go
it's off again get up now you think so
it's just the coke you hole drill okay
when I when I want to do when I don't
want you to get up this is different now
you see hey so you might go well I still
have my knees okay so I'm gonna lower
your hands and take your knees
underneath your butt there you go that's
it okay now watch what happens go back
down I'm gonna move them up towards your
head now try it
are you sure gonna try
hey hey so we're not going to kiss
someone I'm going to do something
different okay push my weight I wanted
to my body cultivation it's all going to
be there I'm already in it not like this
this is not strong this rotation on my
spine lengthen your arm you see it's
just not strong
but this one oh he's not gonna unwind
that arm he has to do that other thing
but that would be a counter okay so make
it part of your technique
the final positioning don't just go here
and then all I'm did where I landed and
now we're gonna do this you understand
put yourself with that elbow ends up on
the front side of your centerline and
you are in the grip but this elbow is
going to end up on this side so no
matter how smooth I go I'm already
always doing that
always the elbow on the other side of my
centerline because I don't want to
rotate I want to go for
I don't want this shoulder to do that
okay I want this shoulder right so this
you're right
hey this okay
what keeps you down is that there's
pressure this way not this height this
way hurts hurts the untrained said they
you okay but you can't get up get
up
I say oh I want this so all that is
there it now go okay
see what you know my hand word cried for
katate dori should be able to do what
what you might have mercy am I gonna
stick with loose breath so what should
be able to do two ballistic okay so you
can't just do whatever you want with
your house okay
oh my hands have to do a certain shape
right here then around this way boom
around this swish boom boom
it's not like this there's a shape that
I want
[Music]
so let's just focus on the grits hat
full right around here okay because
you're not finishing the first move okay
so I have you going like this the first
move is here you're here like that and
then you go around you're gonna end up
at the wrist we have to finish the first
smooth wool you see then out and look
you're at the elbow finish the first
move
cool down here to your thumb goes down
okay then you go out out to the elbow
let's go come on my beard is growing and
holy cow get up in the top
what okay so the second the second are
wool hop the third arm I hear right to
the strike and then don't go right from
here and crap
okay make it circular so the two hands
are helping each other so so this hand
is going to go around right right
TV me
[Music]
so you're throwing it look you're
chopping right now you guys are going
like this you want to do this vortex
Hey
two two engines unique okay the first
engine is two spiraling quit work then
you keep it going where his balance is
mom that part you won't have if you get
gluttonous and you try to take him
straight we need to have this elbow go
this way you see that pay attention to
this my relief which work you see now
this legs gonna go out of the way going
to it what you guys do is you go this
way right or you in turn stock okay but
there's still this I'm gonna help that
elbow go down but it's not here keep
that shape so we just all right by the
other hand would be there right then we
keep that shape and then as I go EDB 10
con that's when it comes down without
moving or changing my structures okay so
pay attention to that part it goes
around and doesn't get greedy and trying
to cut it down here instead beats the
spiraling switch work because anything
that I have to push on pushing back on
me you understand so I don't I'm not
gonna push there I'm just gonna hold
there and let it fall into place so
don't give me
okay let's get any of the I'm pushing on
is pushing back on me okay so when I go
in here I know to you it looks like I'm
manipulating a house but remember if he
was just falling
[Music]
so he's feeling whiney laughs last time
is that it feel soft as happiest
crossed you understand so
so you're pushing on good I'm Xiaomi
what's the problem Go Go Go
pushing on me Go Go what's the problem
who can make it simple around I'm
stronger than her let's all go in again
look I'm stronger than her so your arch
works so you have to figure out how in
your keyboard you shouldn't feel them at
all so you have to resist temptation
where you go I feel that I feel the
corner I can push I can get that that's
what I mean by its gluttonous you're a
greedy bastard and the downside is
you're ready for you don't know me
because whatever that accomplishment is
it doesn't work so you should greet you
should have you greed for the ideal form
which is not be pushing on so you're
trying to figure out Ikey how to
harmonize yin and Yan how to go around
those energies okay
old center boom pass boom okay
it's doing one with my with my body so I
go here and you're like well I'm stuck
but see then my body moves so boom okay
just ignored all those reps before of
your classmates faces having the lemon
sour puss you do realize that right so
clearly it's possible to capture the arm
with these hand maneuvers but you're not
see you don't know what's trapping arm
so go back to the beginning of class
what is actually trapping the harm which
wish part of the hand movement no that's
what a lot of you say and you think it's
the second arm that's why you push down
on it the second arm is doing what no
that's more trapping the second arm is
your position okay after this motion
runs out of it it's a fact in terms of
the spiral the second arm takes
the spiral effect okay but the trap is
what was the first correction the first
correction was here you see that you see
where it is so his arm can't fall here
do you got it so there's no need to have
to grab it here so when you do this part
this comes into his elbow you see and
then his wrist is up here so when you do
like your correction that's what's
making the arm fall you're here like
this you see and you go down in the arm
Falls because it's nothing underneath
the arm you see that so you have to put
something underneath the arm and that is
this part you see right you got that so
this part starts trapping the arm so
it's just there to guide not yet not yet
right until this arm runs out of steam
because I can't go like this
I keep my Center and that's when this
arm starts to take over so to help you
just make sure that this traps doesn't
go here because now you're not under the
arm this trap goes to where your Center
is and by centers not over there my
centers over here so my arm is going to
go here you see and then
the arm can fall okay go